my name is David Austin I am currently a
staff scientist at Tech Nova which is a
biotech company that specializes in
buffers and now we are transitioning to
gene therapy using aav technology
I am one of four siblings I have two
older brothers and a younger sister and
we grew up in Cleveland Heights it's a
nice small little suburb of Cleveland I
was very diverse
that is where you know I got my first
taste of Science in in the greater
scheme of things so I knew growing up
that my career was going to be in
something that did with math and science
just because it was very easy for me I
picked it up fairly quickly and I
actually wanted to be an engineer at
first because I love taking things apart
and putting things together and you know
I always I was always fascinated on how
things worked but what really
transitioned me into science was when my
dad had a health scare we found out that
he had beginning stages of prostate
cancer and that is basically what
transitioned me from being an engineer
to want to do health care and science
after I got my Master's in biology I
didn't really know if I you know wanted
to be a MD or be or go get my PhD so the
nice thing about Vanderbilt is they had
this MD PhD program and this summer
program before
uh uh you know the school started in
that fall and through that summer
program is where I really uh found my
love which was doing actual research I
wanted to be more Hands-On and be you
know on the ground level of you know the
major findings because in my mind I
always always want to help people and I
figured that I can help more people
doing research than actually seeing
patients so
with my sense of just helping the most
people that I can help I decided to get
my PhD and do research and now I am
working at technova as a flow
cytometrist I'm still kind of in
Academia
because I am a Adjunct professor up here
in San Jose and so I do that in the
evening times and my dad always says
find a job that you love to do and you
and it won't be considered a job like I
always tell my friends I'm a perfect
cross between my parents my dad was a
researcher my mom was a fourth grade
teacher and so I love teaching and I
love doing research so it it works for
me because I'm doing what I love
foreign